meanwhile ms-13 has been terrorizing
ordinary people mostly immigrants by the
way in this country for years it's the
deadliest gang in America and it seems
to be turning its sights against
American law enforcement that's not our
take that's what they're saying
in recent weeks Long Island police have
arrested several gang members and
according to informant leaders are
telling their foot soldiers quote it is
time to take the streets back and shoot
a cop like we do in El Salvador issued a
lot of cops in El Salvador they run the
country
Patrick Ryder is commissioner of the
Nassau County Police Department he joins
us tonight mr. honor thanks for coming
on thank you sir for having us so our
understanding of ms-13 is up until now
they've committed a lot of crimes a
number of high-profile killings but
mostly they haven't targeted law
enforcement you think that's changing
well we got our threat last Wednesday
they decided that they were going to put
out notice that foot soldiers that you
were going to take a cop's life just
like they do in El Salvador so why that
why the change they don't like the fact
that we've increased our enforcement
we're going after the ms-13 and all our
gangs out here in Long Alan so from the
increased enforcement they decided they
were going to act back well in return
we're gonna act back where are these
people coming from most of them are
crossing from the borders of both Mexico
and Texas they they find their way up
into the New York area where there is
work for most migrant workers yes but
again these those who don't join the
gangs they get threatened by the gangs
to join them and they go after the young
kids and try to flip them so you've seen
and you may have missed this since
you're busy enforcing the law but here
in Washington ms-13 has had in effect
some high-profile defenders who have
said it's wrong it's immoral it's
probably bigoted actually to target
ms-13 because they're immigrants how
would you respond to that I spend a lot
of time in the in the Hispanic community
and these leaders in the community they
don't want them there they don't want no
part of them in their community and
unfortunately they're given safe haven
with their own and to protect it because
they threaten others and then they now
they're taking the threat to us we're
gonna take it back to them
were you looking at pictures are on the
screen went to El Salvador last summer
and that's a holding
facility with ms-13 members ms-13 has a
huge role in in effect running El
Salvador it's a pretty Varsity operation
they kill cops regularly there and put
many others on the take are you worried
about the gang metastasizing and turning
really violent I mean do you think your
informant could be predicting the future
our informants are both of those threats
that we receive a credible we went out
and we gave the enforcement we are
concerned obviously for the officers
safety all of our officers both here
nassau county the state of new york and
the country whatever color uniform you
wear we have the defendant we are the
first line of defense in this country
from these gang members that want to
take again up these locations and start
enforcing their violence so we have to
bring back a message to them that will
not be accepted well if you maintain
that level of self confidence you'll win
and I hope that politicians don't don't
force you to dial it back because I
think you're right commissioner thank
you